hey guys happy Friday I'm Kelly and I'm
chastity
Justin Tanner still out but they'll be
back next week so we've got your top
five stories of the week
[Music]
just start off destiny two's Leviathan
prestige raid was beaten in an hour
after it went up how with a glitch Oh
for context when team game swap played
the regular version of the raid so not
the hard one we went in blind and it
took us six hours just to make it
halfway so an hour is really really fast
so the procedure aid was delayed is this
the same glitch that deleted no that was
a glitch that prevented ads from
spawning in the boss this is actually
called the coil glitch which is tied to
the ward cliff coil rocket launcher and
it lets you instantly fill up your power
ammo personally I like taking my time
with destiny two's harder late-game
stuff I think part of the fun is
figuring out what you're supposed to do
yeah so I'm not the kind of player
that's going to try to be the world's
first at something but people are kind
of mad that they got the title of
world's first when they use kind of like
a an exploit glitch kind of a cheese dip
basically and so you know I don't know
that's something that I personally would
be mad at but I get it yeah that's
understandable but just do it your best
without the glitch and just be proud of
yourself don't get mad get glad yeah so
next up I heard a Halloween event is
coming to Pokemon go
that is right chastity and that also
means that the first hoenn Pokemon are
going to be introduced to the game so
this is pretty big okay gen 3 Pokemon
finally coming
that's from Ruby and Sapphire if you
don't know very got we got Bennett
Duskull Sableye I love these guys ghost
Pokemon are some of my favorites and I
don't know if there is recognizable
maybe airy maybe but it's still very
cool it's something to keep people
playing the game which I always like and
there's also a Pikachu wearing a witch's
hat and for your character you can get a
Mimi Q hat which is weird because this
Pokemon came out in Sun and Moon it's
not at all the gen 3 Pokemon but I'm
down everybody loves me McHugh he's my
favorite a division of Sony is now
publishing intend to switch and PC games
under a new label
it's called unti z' i think it's
pronounced unties or that so some
upcoming projects include a game called
tiny metal which you can see here it's a
turn-based strategy inspired by Advance
Wars and there are two projects Lissa's
for pc / TBA so we don't know a lot
about those but it's worth noting that
this is a label under Sony
music entertainment not Sony interactive
entertainment or PlayStation Division so
it's a little weird yeah they operate
independently of each other so I
wouldn't get too excited yeah you're not
gonna see Uncharted on your switch or
anything that's a system seller this is
more for indie games to get them to as
many people as possible which is cool
yeah switch got a very big update this
week yep they're adding gameplay capture
they got save data transfer and more we
talked about this yesterday but I want
to emphasize how relieved I am that
update 4.0 adds save data transfer I
just like that I don't have to worry
about upgrading my switch down the line
if they add a model that has better
battery life or something because right
now I kind of feel locked into the
console that I have and so it's nice
that with this update I don't have to
worry about that anymore that's true and
now I can capture my gameplay of Sonic
mania where I keep dying I don't think
anyone wants to watch that but yeah
capture gameplay I would and finally our
top story of the week announced that
they're shutting down visceral games
this will affect the story driven Star
Wars game they've been working on for
some time the studio behind the dead
space series and other titles was
planning a single-player Star Wars game
and they've been working on it and will
be overhauled and moved to a different
EA studio according to EA executive VP
Patrick Sutherland so that EA wants to
take visceral game in a different
direction specifically he said pivots it
was shaping up to be a linear story
based adventure but sterlin talks about
how EA looked at the marketplace and
wants to make a game that players can
quote come back to you and enjoy for a
long time to come and if you read
between the lines this sounds a lot like
destiny yeah so I don't know what kind
of game it's going to be by doubt that
it's going to be a story driven
single-player game anymore it's gonna be
something completely different which is
unfortunate because myself and other
service fans were really looking forward
to a game like this like this is
something we needed it could have been
like the best Star Wars RPG ever but who
knows how viscera will be shut down and
development will move to EA Vancouver
where the game will shift towards an
experience that quote allows for more
variety and player agency this girl has
been around for almost 20 years and was
known as EA Redwood Shores until May
2009 so there were a lot of high hopes
around this game because of Amy Hennig
who we know from her work on uncharted
she was the senior creative director on
the Star Wars game and so we had a lot
of hope that this would be good like a
lot of Star Wars fans in my
we're hoping for this story-driven
single-player game and now who knows
what it's going to be but it's really
it's really heartbreaking and our heart
goes out to anybody affected by the
change of visceral let us know what you
think of today's stories in the comments
below and don't forget to check out the
evolution of grand theft auto tomorrow
on GameSpot calm jess and Dan will be
back on Monday but we will be back
Wednesday while they're at pax Australia
so if you're in Australia say hi to them
and we'll see you next week bye destiny
choose raid but a lot of people are
pretty mad but they got the title of
wards he could chew in a witch hat by in
Redwood Shores until mate oh alright